der 17 märz 2014 wird wohl in die physik
geschichte eingehen aber einsteins big
bang theory ist wohl belegt das
universum hat sich tatsächlich in zehn
sechs millionste sekunden zu einer größe
von vielen milliarden lichtjahren
ausgedehnt es ist der anfang einer neuen
ära so der potsdamer gravitationsphysik
bernard schutz der direktor des dortigen
albert einstein instituts die entdeckung
ist so bahnbrechend dass es bis zu ihrer
veröffentlichung drei jahre gedauert hat
der leiter des experiments john kovac
wollte wirklich sicher sein dass am
bizeps teleskop am südpol wirklich
gravitationswellen aus der ersten
sekunde des weltalls entdeckt wurden
für ihn steht es jetzt fest die signale
sind echt wir wissen jetzt wirklich wie
der big bang der urknall stattgefunden
hat die signale selbst die
gravitationswellen sind dabei mit einem
trick aufgespürt worden sie selbst sind
nicht beobachte aber sie müssten spuren
in der hintergrundstrahlung des weltalls
hinterlassen haben
sie ist quasi die restwärme strahlung
des urknalls ihre temperatur liegt nur
noch bei knapp 3 grad kelvin also knapp
über dem absoluten nullpunkt
in dieser mikrowellenstrahlung müssten
laut der theorie minimale unterschiede
in der polarisation zu finden sein
sie würden die gravitationswellen wieder
spielen
diese polarisation beschreibt die lage
der lichtwellen im raum wird nicht von
einer oberfläche zb reflektiert wird es
polarisiert mit einem pol filter kann es
dann herausfiltern
wie bei dieser motorhaube genau das
machen auch die gravitationswellen des
urknalls mit dem mikrowellen der
hintergrund standen also das haben sie
damals beim urknall verursacht mit einem
speziellen detector den die nasa
entwickelt hat wurde dann am set to
begonnen zu messen ähnlich dem pol
filter kann der detektor die jeweiligen
polarisation der hintergrundstrahlung
bestimmen und so sieht es aus die
gravitationswellen haben zu einem ganz
bestimmten muster der polarisation in
der hintergrundstrahlung geführt wir
können jetzt die gravitationswellen der
ersten sekunden bruchteile des weltalls
sehen und es ist so gut wie gewiss der
urknall war so dramatisch wie er bisher
nur vermutet wurde
das universum hat sich tatsächlich nur
zehn sechs zehntelsekunden zu einer
größe von vielen milliarden lichtjahren
ausgedehnt die konsequenzen sind
wirklich unglaublich
mit dieser entdeckung sind wir auf dem
weg zur weltformel ein riesenschritt
weiter gekommen
denn jetzt können wir den moment
beobachten indem die vereinbarkeit von
quantenphysik und relativitätstheorie
entdeckt werden könnte es ist der moment
neben es wahrscheinlich nur eine urkraft
gab es ist der tatsächliche beginn von
allem was wird diese entdeckung jetzt
alles verändern diskutiert es in den
kommentaren mehr bahnbrechende
wissenschafts news gibt es hier oder die
infotecs unter dem video werden jetzt
aliens gefunden
rekord 715 exoplaneten aufgespürt oder
dramatischer klimawandel steht vor der
tür
jetstream wird langsamer vergesst nicht
ein kostenloses abo dazu lassen und hier
oben gehts zum blog mit noch mehr
wissenschafts - also bis dann bleibt
dran